new rules to make it easier for online  stores to stream music across europe's  borders are on the table as eu ministers  meet in brussels  the draft laws aim to encourage the  creation of eu-wide online music  services and ensure that the rights of  artists are better protected and their  royalties paid more quickly  instead of having to obtain copyright  licenses in every eu country online  providers would be able to get them from  management organizations operating  across borders on behalf of the artists  the rules would apply to online  retailers like apple and amazon but also  to streaming services such as spotify  and the system is likely to encourage  new providers to set up shop  the result should mean more and better  online music services for consumers and  cheaper prices  the measures were passed by a european  parliament committee on november 4 and  are expected to easily pass a final vote  in full plenary early in 2014 before  they enter force